for the members that just came in we're
at ease for the fall of the gavel
so everybody presently in the room
except senator sass and tell us has
spoken
there's still time between now and the
time we scheduled voted senator sass or
senator Tillis wants to say anything
then we we continue to stand at ease mr.
chairman given what's happening in the
anteroom
I think if some more time is needed I
think you'd get a unanimous consent to
push the road back pretty easily if you
needed a few more minutes I'm we made a
decision of order 130 if there's some
reason to change that then we'll have to
change it but I'm not even going getting
a discussion about that right now
fair enough
[Music]
gotta get
I recess the meeting until the fall of
the gavel we're going to take action
with a motion that's before us we got to
make sure that we have a quorum
[Music]
as a as a point of personal privilege
I'm going to call on senator flake to
speak normally we would start to vote
right now but it's a point of personal
privilege I would call on senator flake
oh thank you I've been speaking with a
number of people on the other side we've
had conversations ongoing for a while
with regard to making sure that we do
due diligence here and I think it would
be proper to delay the floor vote for up
to but not more than one week in order
to let the FBI continue to do an
investigation limited in time and scope
to the current allegations that are
there and limit in time to no more than
one week and I will vote to advance the
bill to the floor with that
understanding and I've spoken to a few
other members who on my side of the
aisle that may be supportive as well but
that's my position I I think that that
we we ought to do what we can to make
sure that that we do all due diligence
with a nomination this important and I
want to say that this committee has
acted properly and the chairman has been
over backwards to do investigations from
this committee and to delay this vote in
this committee for a week so that judge
or that that board dr. Ford could be
heard and she was yesterday so so that's
with that agreement I will vote to a
dance bill to the floor
torkoal just wait just one second ken
ken Diane when are we voting on that see
we are voting on the motion to report
the nomination to the floor
the clerk will call the roll
wait that's not my understanding of what
mr. chairman let's the senator explain
it he adequate that is my my my
understanding and if the Democrats could
speak to it of Chris or you was talked
about before that the Democrats would
accept and endorse a one-week a FBI
investigation limited in time and scope
so ensure the deciding since you're the
deciding vote here will vote and then if
there's any sort of discussion we'll go
do that after the vote call the roll no
the nominee no
the nominee will be reported to the mr.
chairman may I be recognized yes
Thank You mr. chairman I just want to
thank my friend and colleague senator
flake and thank you for giving us the
time today to have a conversation a
number of my colleagues have asked for a
one-week delay in order that there might
be an FBI investigation of what
allegations are currently before this
committee I respect senator flakes view
that in his opinion it was best to
respect your having given dr. Ford the
time to be heard yesterday and advance
the nominee to the floor but it is my
hope that we could work together on a
bipartisan basis to diligently pursue an
FBI investigation within the next week
not for the purpose of delay but for the
purpose of investigating further either
allegations made by dr. Ford or others
with a goal towards demonstrating a
bipartisan commitment to diligently
investigating these allegations Thank
You mr. chairman Thank You senator flake
senator Feinstein thank you
I would support that motion I think we
do need this investigation matter of
fact I sort of misunderstood senator
flake what you were doing I thought it
included a one-week investigation so I
would like to support the motion for
that investigation miss chairman is
chairman we'll take turns here I love
this committee but we're not the
majority leader senator flake has made
clear what it would take him to be
comfortable on a final passage vote but
it doesn't matter what we say here this
will be up to Senator Schumer and
Senator McConnell so it is completely up
to them yeah and I think I just made
himself very clear and smooth for me
that Senator Leahy fairly well mr.
Chairman I want to make sure because
this is someone on precedent when I do
agree with a senator from Arizona that
we should have this further
investigation so my understanding is
during the week that that is taking
place
there will be no action on the floor of
the United States Senate on on this
nomination that correct that cannot I
cannot say that let me say again I'm not
making I can't make that commitment for
the the leadership I can only say that I
would be only comfortable moving forward
on the floor I'll move it out of
committee but I will only be comfortable
moving on the floor until the FBI has
done more investigation than they have
already it may not take them a week I
understand that some of these witnesses
may not want to discuss anything further
but I think we're we owe them due
diligence your chairman just a minute
all I have said to Senator flake is that
I would advocate for the position he
took but I don't control that senator
mr. chairman yes sir senator Klobuchar
mr. chairman there are other senators as
well who may be interested in this
negotiation on the Republican side and
there's not really a set agreement here
all of us had already said we were
voting now it is simply a center flake
working with all of us to say for the
good of the Senate and the good of the
court the American people deserve to
have the facts followed up on and I
really appreciate his willingness to do
that and that is what this is about this
is simply about and by the way if
Senator McConnell wants to go forward in
light of that and we still have several
senators that haven't said how they're
voting on this nominee I actually think
this is very important what just
happened right now so it doesn't have to
have an agreement it is one senator
who's standing up senator Cornyn
mr. chairman I just want to express my
appreciation to Senator flake for
allowing in this process to move forward
there's some difference of opinion among
us as to what exactly the FBI
investigation would consist of some of
us think the it has been concluded and
supplemented by of this committees
investigation others disagree with that
but I respect the fact that not only
senator flake advocated to give dr. Ford
chance to appear in front of the
committee which was the right thing to
do but also that he's allowed this
process to move forward subject to
further discussions about what the FBI
may or may not be able to come up with
but certainly he maintains his right to
cast his vote yea or nay as he sees fit
and maintains significant leverage that
way but I appreciate his his support for
a full and fair hearing for dr. Ford and
judge Cavanaugh as well as his
willingness to allow this to go forward
subject to his his request mr. chairman
if I threw the chair could ask a
question of senator flake does your
Amendment include continuing the
investigation during this period of time
if I can respond
there is no amendment I'm simply stating
and the discussion that we had between
us all is that I would hope and I think
we had some agreement before that the
Democrats who have been I think
justifiably uncomfortable moving ahead
could could publicly in an effort to
bring this country together say that we
would feel better I'm not expecting them
to vote yes but not to complain that an
FBI investigation has not occurred and
and I that's what I'm trying to do who
this country's being ripped apart here
and and we've got to make sure that we
do deal with due diligence I think this
committee has done a good job but I do
think that we can have a short pause and
and make sure that the FBI can
investigate my understanding is that
some of us would have to and I'm
prepared to do it make a request to the
White House to ask the FBI to do that
investigation it would be short and
limited in scope to the current
allegations that have been made mr.
chairman
I I would just encourage Democrats who
we'd talked to before to endorse that
kind of thing that
that we can then move on mr. chairman
because of the to our rule we're
adjourned
what yeah we did the other tool our
rules we knew we had to get this all
done well is it done it's flakes argue
is it gonna happen or do you cut off a
vote no we didn't have a notion and for
us this is all a gentleman and women's
agreement that was several men and women
everywhere but I'm committed you're 11
single he's committed to
hey John